[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
oh yeah
now as you notice this one came out on
wednesday uh
and uh that's on p on patreon on
wednesday and then thursday
on youtube and that's the thing that's
going to be happening now i know a lot
of you guys were like what the [ __ ]
happened to the podcast but that's what
it's going to be because we are
streamlining the way we do this
and we want it to be more current
sometimes i mention things in the
podcast that happen uh right when they
happen because we do a podcast and then
later on um it it it doesn't come out to
like a week and a half and it's like why
the [ __ ] do you care about the super
bowl at that point so we're recording on
mondays
and then uh we are dropping it
wednesdays and thursdays so that's much
better than we recorded a week we
usually we used to record a week ahead
of time so it's going to be a better
show i think ultimately um
so that's that that's why it's a day
late it's not actually a day late it's
by design and now this is how it's gonna
be from now on um
so that's good and um we've got merch
the don't push me merch selling like
hotcakes you know
everyone everyone is who they are and
when the outside world happens you got
to remain you got to remember to remain
yourself don't be pushed and that's not
your fault if you get pushed right
that's someone else encroaching on your
space let me be me basically you're
saying and don't push me right you don't
want right chris coming out or you don't
want whoever coming out right everyone's
got their own version of whatever that
don't push me [ __ ] is
um
and you know it's the americana design
that's all good it's the americana
design and you got a hat that people
think that maybe you served in the
[ __ ] goddamn navy a while ago
yeah don't push me but um yeah so that's
what's up dude uh well okay good
wow man you know what it's crazy i feel
like a lot of stuff happened this week
just personally like right now even just
starting off
um
i had a we had a
a bit of a get-together for the super
bowl yesterday and then the next day
which is today the place was a mess
kristen had to study for school um and
she has a test today and so she didn't
want to have to clean up the place so
she went online and found a
place that comes and um cleans the house
and
there was all sorts of [ __ ] like it was
a potluck so everyone had ribs and [ __ ]
and it was like cakes and just wraps
everywhere and so these people came to
do it uh two people two women uh one
younger woman one older woman and um
kristen had to leave and she was like
you gotta deal with this and i was like
okay i guess i'll deal with it you know
johnny doesn't deals with [ __ ] but i
guess
johnny has to deal with [ __ ] at this
point right because she's got to go do
her thing and study at the library right
okay
could study here but it's all good
that's not for me to say that's what she
wanted to do that's what she needed and
that's fine all right so
what i
uh did was stay at home okay
um
and they show up
and the younger woman you know she's 25
30 or something and she's like uh hi
we're here to clean the house and i was
like okay cool now we have cleaning
ladies but they work on fridays all
right so she wanted this [ __ ] done now
so they're coming monday so this is the
different cleaning ladies because the
cleaning ladies that we have they're
booked solid because they are trustable
and that is what you pay top dollar for
i've offered them to clean other friends
houses and they were like uh and they
were like okay cool how much is it i
tell them how much and they're like oh i
could get somebody to clean this [ __ ] up
for 40 and i'm like yeah but that's a
crack [ __ ] you understand right these
people trust costs money so when my
cleaning ladies ask for a raise i go
like this okay
i guess i'm daddy warbucks at this point
because the trust costs money right
and i trust them because they've been
with me for 15 plus years
okay
and so um
now i got these random people come in to
wash my house okay and they're coming
and as soon as i got the dogs locked up
now i got four dogs in a cage right now
four dogs and then i have cooper okay
because our
uh
uh the uh calvin is at grandma's house
and we're watching someone else's dog
okay it's just so much so much [ __ ] is
going on it's a lot okay
um
and so
the the the people come and and cooper's
the only one out of the cage and cooper
runs outside when i open the door and
and
the young one is like hi i'm here to
clean the house and the the older lady
is like okay by are you gonna put this
dog up
and i'm like
hello uh what she's like you gotta put
this dog up and i'm like oh yeah okay
he's very friendly i'll just put him
i'll put him upstairs and i hold him and
she's like not coming in the house and
the younger woman is like come in it's
okay he's got the dog and she's like
okay as long as he's gonna put him up
and i'm like i'll put the dog upstairs
it's all good no no no big deal and so i
did that so i was like very weird way to
start the thing okay very weird way to
start the thing to come into a house
thinking that i'm just gonna have attack
dogs fly out and go for your juggler
right okay but i understand stranger
things have happened and you're coming
into a foreign stranger's house okay
fair enough i put the dog upstairs and
then i come back down and they're like
very they're very nice okay we're good
everything good this is good the younger
lady says to the older lady um are you
good with cleaning this and the older
lady says yeah this is easy and the
younger lady says okay i have to leave
and go drop someone else to another
location and i go like this okay sounds
weird but what do i know i'm not in the
cleaning business
what do i know right
i'm not in the clinton business so now
there's one person in my house and it's
for some reason weirder for one stranger
to be in your house than two strangers
to be in the house right because this
two strangers can bounce the [ __ ] off
each other and be strange together but
when one of the stranger leaves all that
strangeness that the one stranger has
that's left is directed towards you so
now i got to deal with the strangeness
okay and it's from this older lady that
is like
so i go upstairs and i let her i'm like
look the only rooms we need to be clean
are these two downstairs rooms and she's
like this is a very nice house a very
nice house here's another thing if
you're a stranger and you come into
someone's house don't compliment their
house makes it feel like you're gonna
get robbed okay don't do that i've seen
too many moves you walk into a house all
right wow very nice wow wow all of a
sudden it seems like i'm gonna get held
up at knife point okay
so i said yeah
very yeah nice house thank you very much
i really appreciate it there's only two
rooms you need to clean so i would go
upstairs i let her do her thing right
because i don't want to be in the way
and i don't want her to feel like she
has to talk to me or she doesn't have to
talk to me so she's just cleaning the
shits
i'll be upstairs about three or four
times i hear this
um
so the first time i hear um
i'm like
okay i guess i go down
i go down i say yes hello and she says
hi yeah um do you have uh trash bags i
thought three would do it but i need i
need more and i say
oh sure yeah they're right here okay i'm
so sorry i'm like it's fine just trash
bags he's fine
go back upstairs
um
that this is how she's saying excuse me
sir
just like hoping i'm going to understand
the confusion has to do with me like
like i don't know what the [ __ ] um is
for it could be because somebody came in
and slashed her neck i have no [ __ ]
idea
um i come down what do you want me to do
with this game she says
it's a game that kristen played last
night with some people i'm like i don't
know just put in the box i guess and
then you could just put it under the
thing with the other games she's like oh
over there i say yeah okay cool okay
so then i'm upstairs for a little bit
and guess what i did i did some gangster
[ __ ] i left the house for 10 minutes
nobody was in the house except her but
then i felt bad that i left the house
right i felt bad that i left the house
so i came back in because i was like she
could be literally robbing me blind but
i wanted to trust
right i wanted to trust because she was
in my house and [ __ ] she could kill
me
so i left the house and then i felt
weird but i came back i came back and
when i came back she was like i'm pretty
much done and i said okay i go upstairs
and then i hear um
so i come back down
and i say yes and she says i'm so sorry
can i use your phone for some reason my
phone isn't working i said do you want
my wi-fi and she said sure i gave her my
wi-fi it wasn't working for some reason
i don't know maybe her phone is off now
so she's like can you call the person to
pick me up and i say okay i call her
text her no response yay
dude can you turn my headphones down yay
yay dude no response yay so now i'm like
okay cool and she sit she's sitting
there and she's like i don't know why
she's not i don't know why she's not uh
picking up and i said oh okay well
whatever she'll come we'll figure it out
and she was like okay because it's just
weird she's not picking me up and i'm
like don't say that too much don't say
that too much because then it's
absolutely weird maybe just wait for the
ride and we'll see what happens and
she's like okay so i go upstairs and
then i hear um
i come back down i'm like yes and she
says well i tried to get in touch with
the
the the business people and then the
other people and you know i was just
helping her out for a day and i don't
even work for her but i was just helping
her out and this is the last time i
helped her out and i go
uh oh
everything is unraveling
and i'm
alone with this person
uh oh
i'm a famous guy
i'm entering fuckedville
okay so i say oh we'll figure it out
don't worry about it
and then she was like okay
um and she was like cause i don't know
she knows i have a nervous condition
now she's got a condition
so now she's in my house alone i'm in my
house alone she's cleaning the house
done with it she did a pretty good job
except for the floors they're sticky
and she says she drops this i've got a
nervous condition on me so i'm like okay
well is there anyone else i could call
and she said well did she not call you
back yet i said no and she said i just
don't know why my phone's not working
this is that doesn't seem to be my fault
and i'm like let's just not even talk
about fault
let's not even talk about fault
and she's like do you think you could
drop me off and i said well
no
and the answer is just because i mean
there's so many reasons that i'm just
going to lump them all into because
i don't want to be alone in my house
with you i don't want to be alone in my
car with you and also
i don't want to drive all the way to
olympic in brea because that's where you
need to go and um so now i'm texting
kristen hey great hire
stranger in our house telling me she's
got a nervous condition hey great hire
and she was like okay it's okay i'm
sorry let me be on your team and i'm
like okay
then she starts
crying
and i don't mean kristin
the person
actually let me rephrase that
this stranger in my house
starts crying
you have entered
fuckedville
oh i'm the mayor now
they voted me in
oh excuse me hello you're the mayor of
fuckedville what do we do here oh i
didn't want this position it's a
democracy and they voted for you
okay
well this stranger's uh
first order of business strangers crying
in your house mayor what are we going to
do oh i don't know
and kristen says
uber her
and as she says uber her the lady's
crying and she says well because she
knows i have a heart condition and i oh
you got two conditions
hey
i got a condition
don't let people with two conditions be
alone in your house with you
that's a standing condition i have
see i have a heart condition i can't
walk that far all the way to alabama i
don't even know where i'm walking i
don't know where i am she says i don't
know where i am
so i'm like all right well um
i'll get you an uber i get an uber i got
to download the [ __ ] app cause i
don't uber you know johnny drives a lot
he's got [ __ ] i mean the cars the
cars that he has alone why the [ __ ]
would he take an uber dude i mean the
inside of my one [ __ ] it looks like it's
that time of the month obviously i got a
[ __ ] head rest on my head rest i
swear to god i got the my pillow guys
seeing me drive by and go that's a good
idea because it looks comfy as [ __ ] when
i'm in there
you know what i'm saying
the guts are open when i lower my
windows
okay
and not to mention i'm bossing it up i
mean i when i step out my car everyone
expects the [ __ ] on me armenian but
it's not it's just me it's a white guy
it's a guy who's basically translucent
who doesn't get a tan at all i'm the
color of [ __ ] off death
all right
and i step out dude but he's the same
color as his mobile isn't he
is he's the same color as mobile what
color is chris he's matte pearl white oh
for [ __ ] sake he's mango white oh [ __ ]
that's the color i am mango white
oh for [ __ ] i didn't know mangoes are
white that's a [ __ ]
they they figured out how to [ __ ]
make a conglomerate dude so um
so now uh she's like i was like all
right well look just relax so now i'm
her coach and her [ __ ] therapist and
[ __ ] i'm like just relax we'll get it
done i'm getting an uber
okay okay should i go what should i do i
was like just sit tight
she's like how far away is it i was like
seven minutes oh good and she's like
should i go eight outside what color is
the car who's the lady i'm like look
look you're asking way too many
questions
kristen's like i don't want to come in
yet i'm she was getting home she's like
i'm scared i'm like it's fine the lady's
so frail it's all good and then the lady
got picked up and left
and then kristen wasn't come i was like
i thought she came home i was like where
are you i text you where she's like i'm
down the street i don't want to come in
yet i'm like
everything's fine come in
jesus christ man
what a day
and then i got [ __ ] calvin with my
nanny over at grandma's house and and
and and they were supposed to be back at
1 15
and the [ __ ] my mom is like
trying to convince my nanny to have
calvin knapp in the [ __ ] at her house
she didn't even have all the things
how's he gonna nap he doesn't have his
[ __ ] sleep sack dude
and then nanny's texting me i don't know
grandma's like kind of like [ __ ]
taking bogart in this situation i'm like
oh [ __ ] dude i got a nervous breakdown i
got a cleaning lady having a nervous
breakdown in my house that i've never
met before i got a stranger telling me
about her two conditions and and my
mom's trying to [ __ ] force calvin
asleep in not a crib
so anyway that's how my day's been going
and we got a lot of [ __ ] to talk about
and that's just what [ __ ] just
happened dude
dude the [ __ ] um as soon as as soon
as the and she kept asking me too are
your dogs still la are your dogs still
up
that's how she kept saying are your dogs
still up i'm like they're stirring
they're not coming out it's all good
don't even worry about it worry about
your heart condition that's the thing
so crazy and dude i've had the [ __ ]
bloody guts mobile for a [ __ ] week
now guess how many dude amazing dude
have i had did i have [ __ ] did i was
it a great car yes dude did i have a
[ __ ] amazing car yes is the [ __ ]
exterior mango white yes it is is i have
[ __ ] really low run flat tires yes
did i flatten two of them yes at
different times yes so is it more
annoying a yes dude should i flatten
them both at the same time obviously it
would have been less annoying yes was
one of them with a nail and one of them
need to replace the whole tire for 500
yes is it okay yes they did it in the
day it's fine but still did i have a
sport spare that i could do it no
because the run flat tires are supposed
to be better you could drive on them for
50 [ __ ] miles but why would i do that
when obviously the rims cost probably
like two [ __ ] dudes
yes i wouldn't do that dude
amazing two flat tires in [ __ ] one
week with the new whip
[ __ ]
and i [ __ ]
oh this was the best dude it's just dude
life you know life
like sometimes life is the [ __ ] you
know what life is
life is like
the guy in the doorway
and you're just like
and he's having a conversation with
somebody inside the place
that you're [ __ ]
trying to get into and you're just like
guy needs to obviously [ __ ] move
i got to get in there and the guy's got
his back to me and he's having a and
it's some [ __ ] big
backed [ __ ] just talking to
somebody in a goddamn panera bread and
you're like i'm trying to get a [ __ ]
goddamn i'm trying to get a
bowl i want to get a [ __ ] a bread
bowl
and like that's life life is that guy
and you're you're just like trying to
eat by you don't want to touch him
and so he so i told you we're building a
house jesus all these [ __ ] problems i
sound like such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know i know people are out
there starving but whatever these are my
problems one time i [ __ ] was like
dude i was bitching about my problems to
bobby lee and he was like do you
understand how good you have it and i
was like [ __ ] dude problems are
just as big as however the [ __ ]
problems are in the person's life i was
like yeah people are around there with
no eyeballs but that's not me i got
eyeballs so my problem is somebody
having a nervous breakdown in my house
that's trying to clean it
so anyway kristin you know i told you
we're building a house
and we go to go have a meeting with the
people who are the architects of the
[ __ ] house and i'm with kristen and
we're driving to the [ __ ] architects
and she's like wait wake up and so i
wake up and she goes dude this is the
[ __ ] it's the little [ __ ] in life man
i'm sleeping you know i sleep in you
know how i do it and i'm not apologetic
about it that's how i do it i work late
sometimes and i sleep in and i'm not
sorry about that i you know as you go
out through life you you you apologize
about a lot of certain things but one
thing i don't apologize about is getting
that sleep because if i don't get that
sleep i get [ __ ] canker sores and i
want to [ __ ] go to bed all the time
and i'm tired i'm laying i'm falling
asleep
so
so i'm like okay
um
i wanna uh i wanna she's like she's like
hey we have that meeting at 11 a.m
you got to wake up um earlier than you
normally do
and and go to an and take a shower and
so i'm like all right cool i couldn't
sleep the night before 10 o'clock
she wakes me up the meeting's at 11 30
10 o'clock she wakes me up
i know i [ __ ] i know i know you're
like you sleep to ten yeah i do but also
i [ __ ] work hard and i do my [ __ ] all
right
i'm i'm i'm a productive member of us of
society
um i can't imagine if this is the first
time everyone anyone ever heard this
podcast they would [ __ ] immediately
hate me but the fans you ride with me
and you ride hard
all right so here's the deal
i am now
uh awake
and she comes in
and she's like hey do you want to take a
shower first or do you want me to take a
shower first
and i said well what's the deal and she
was like i can shower first or you can
shower first
and i said okay um
it doesn't matter
she's like okay
so she leaves the room
and i'm like all right i'm up
i'm gonna take a shower so i take a
shower
i get out of the shower
i get ready i'm ready then she gets in
the shower so now guess what could have
[ __ ] slept way longer it doesn't
matter it's all good okay it doesn't
matter
so she's taking a shower
now i'm like you know me when i wake up
i like to get a coffee that's what i do
now i didn't use the [ __ ] coffee
maker that i have because it needs to be
cleaned now that's fine dude i get it
because guess what we have to go
somewhere so if we have to go somewhere
we can stop at that [ __ ] coffee bean
and tea leaf right that's what i got
right here with the purple straw
[Music]
so i'm like that's what we're gonna do
and she comes down late way too late to
leave and i say okay let's go and she
says okay i'm gonna do my makeup in the
car and i say okay incredible you're not
ready but all good right hey by the way
it's incredible you're not ready
especially since you started it off by
waking me up saying who wants to take a
shower first i took one and then 10
minutes later you took one incredible
you're not ready but it's all good but
we got to get a coffee on the way there
because you know that's how i do right
and she was like okay we get down the
hill and she goes chris can we just
knock out a coffee no
no
whoa i'm pissed dude she changed her
mind in [ __ ] five minutes and it
wasn't because of any other reason that
she thought we were gonna be too late
when we were already too late because of
her i yes dude
yes
man ladies late and i've got no caffeine
in me ah yes
now i feel [ __ ] about complaining
because why are we going because we're
going to
meet somebody to build us a house so yes
i've got no room to complain because i'm
rich
yes dude but my problems are my problems
and so i say baby can we just get a
coffee it's on the way and she's like
it's going to take too long so i pull up
the apple i'm driving and she's like
don't text and drive i said i'm getting
the app so i could just run in the place
get the coffee it'll save time she's
like i don't want you texting and
driving so now she doesn't want me
getting a coffee and doesn't want me
using the app while i'm driving because
she thinks it's dangerous
and i can't complain because i'm rich
so i'm driving i'm driving on the way
and it's all good i'm like you know what
fine she's like they'll have coffee
there now i don't know why she's saying
it because they obviously don't have
iced americanos at the goddamn
architecture place all they have is bad
stale coffee
and that's 100 obvious and it's fine to
know that but it's not fine to say that
because you know you're just going to
piss me off more because you know that's
not what i want yes and we keep moving
so we're rolling dude we're rolling
we're rolling and the bloody guts are
getting all over okay
and i realize you know what i'm in a
nice boss armenian car okay it's okay
cool i'm a bit tony soprano because i've
got the beautiful tint on i've even got
the front window tint like i said nobody
could tell
that i'm that it might it's my car's
time of the month
except for the [ __ ] maybe somebody on
southwest airline in the middle of a
flight right because
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] isn't tinted okay
so we're going there and we're driving
and and and we're driving and we're
halfway there we're more than halfway
there we're not halfway there we're more
than halfway there and kristen says
okay well we're going to be really late
and i say well why don't you email them
since i can't use my phone because i'm
driving and tell them and give them a
heads up that we're going to be late and
she says
okay
and i understand that she's a little bit
stung because i said she want you know
what i mean i'm like well i can't do it
well you said i can't use the app so
what if those are the rules then i can't
be driving and you got to be [ __ ]
doing the thing and she's like okay you
got me i touched it was a little bit of
a touche moment right
so she was like okay
um
she's emailing and she's going like this
she's quiet for a little bit and then
she goes
babe
i say yup and she says
the meetings next wednesday
but what do i do with all this anger
well okay that may be true
sweetheart
what do i do
with more than two carry-ons
of anger
i guess we have to pay extra
i guess we have to
check some of these anger bags
now why am i mad
i'm mad because of the shower thing and
i was rushed and i didn't need to be i'm
mad because i can still be asleep and
i'm mad because we drove out of our way
all the way to a place that we wouldn't
have gone
if it wasn't for this meeting that oh by
the way didn't exist
until the future
and why am i mad i'm mad because i've
been being told what to do not text not
get a coffee and i'm mad because i
didn't get to do my thing but it's okay
because i've been to a lot of therapy
and johnny learns a lot
okay
so i start kind of just trying to relax
i say nothing i realize you know what
today's [ __ ] already
and it's one of those things where when
you realize that the day's [ __ ] like
when you realize a day's going badly
that's when you're mad but when you
realize a day's [ __ ]
you're not so mad right because what are
you gonna do
you're the mayor of fuckedville
they voted you in
so
i just turn right and she starts
laughing and she says well i guess we
can get a coffee now
little bit of a [ __ ] touche a little
bit of a [ __ ] you know a shank to my
side but it's all good
it's all good because i'm sitting in
bloody guts anyway
turn around
start driving to i guess a coffee place
and all of a sudden
we actually get hit with a homing
missile
at least that's what it seemed like what
happened was i had a pop hole pothole i
hit a pothole okay not pop hole because
that's not what it is but i hit a
pothole and i made a joke that my tire
popped i go oh my god jesus
i go like that and kristen laughs and
then
over my dash the tire thing comes out
and it starts like all they got they got
47 pieces of air right the psi they got
47 pieces of air in my tire everything's
at 47 except for the one that hit the
pothole it goes 47 46 45 44 and it's
going down dude and it goes it gets down
to nine eight and i'm like i pull over
dude it's gone these run flat time there
it's gone dude i'm rolling on only the
rim and so i'm like for [ __ ] sake dude
and i said you know this is gonna take
an hour and she's like no it's not
oh
yes it is
she thought it was going to take 25
minutes for triple a to come and switch
the tire that by the way we don't have
because they don't keep it because
they're run flat tires and you can't put
on run flat tires like that so i had to
get a tow truck and they had to come
three hours later and they had to bring
it to mercedes-benz beverly hills and we
had to pretend like we wanted to go to
that shitty coffee shop for three hours
oh
no
i'm in the mail
and she dressed nicely
she dressed nicely because she wanted to
impress the architect people she dressed
in a nice dress so now we're walking
around this [ __ ] residential area in
the nice dress like we're some [ __ ]
hooligans that are trying to trick you
it was a [ __ ] day dude so now i got
two flat tires in one week
all i'm trying to say is my [ __ ]
life's hard dude
life's that guy in the [ __ ] doorway
that you're asking to move
kind of like a [ __ ]
so it's all good they fixed it up nice
and uh that's that
but let's get to the [ __ ] [ __ ]
i gotta the thing about the [ __ ] uh
super bowl is like just
okay they're playing the game and all
that [ __ ]
i would say this man about the halftime
show
you know there's very rarely a good
halftime show and i'm all prepared to
just think about how [ __ ] it's gonna
be but this halftime show [ __ ] ripped
when 50 cent [ __ ] came down off the
thing i was like jesus christ dude by
the way have you ever tried to hang
upside down have you ever actually got
on like an inversion table or something
like that it feels like your eyes are
going to pop out of your head and your
ears are going to explode so how the
[ __ ] can [ __ ] chubby scent do it i
mean dude he was upside down by the way
he looked big enough i know everyone's
making fun of him they're all doing that
hacky joke [ __ ] oh it's not 50 cent
he's a dollar now okay i get it fine
funny ha ha so many people did the same
joke that's just one of those jokes that
you type in how come while you're typing
you don't realize oh everyone's going to
be out there google it first they're
doing it too but he did a [ __ ] upside
down hang and he what is he [ __ ] 250
at least
bro how did his head not pop open for
real he was like you can find me in the
club just [ __ ] upside down and i made
a joke about how like he didn't even
know he's a part of the [ __ ] [ __ ] um
when we were at the thing we were at the
[ __ ] super bowl while watching it and
i was like oh this is how he woke up in
the morning he didn't even know he was a
part of it till right now and that made
me laugh and everyone laughed but dude
he was sleeping upside down
or no he was upside down just doing this
[ __ ] rapping upside down hard enough to
be upside down try to be upside down
dude go try to be upside down after this
podcast you can't do it you're going to
be like oh [ __ ] this sucks 50 cent was
just ch so everyone's making fun about
how [ __ ] big he was how about the
fact that the [ __ ] hung upside
down and did the first verse of a song
that [ __ ] came out in 1999
the guy ripped dude
that ripped that ripped that he was on
it i mean i don't you know i go back and
forth on 50 cent but and then when
eminem came out forget it and dre came
out and he was like i've been in this
rap game for 30 [ __ ] years and
everyone was like oh [ __ ] i'm old as
[ __ ]
but that's what they do though dude they
never what's up with the football why
don't they they never try to draw in the
younger crowd i guess they don't need to
right because football is such a [ __ ]
establishment
it's such a like i know how like eminem
took the knee for kaepernick and nfl
just didn't want that they asked him
could we do that anyway an nfl was like
oh [ __ ] of course not
and eminem did it anyway the only white
guy which is hilarious
um and then dr dre didn't say his line
[ __ ] the police or i'm still still not
giving a [ __ ] about what the [ __ ] the
line is i don't know but he didn't do it
they rewrote that too because obviously
the nfl didn't want that line in there
it's a corporation my babies that's why
thank god we're on goddamn patreon man
[ __ ] him you want to be an ad you want
to be a sponsor or not good what doesn't
matter dude i got my patreon babies and
you're killing it six dollars a [ __ ]
month dude
patreon.com sign up sign up my babies
sign up and i'll tell you [ __ ] the
police all day long or sometimes i'll be
like i'm friends with the police i'll
tell you how i feel about the police
each week it goes back and forth dude we
need the police by the way we need them
right now we need them you know why
everything's [ __ ] on fire in los
angeles
and the [ __ ] the sheriff and the d.a
they're at odds you know in los angeles
how about garcetti dude not wearing a
mask getting a picture taken again dude
the third time the third time he's
sitting there with his mask around his
[ __ ] arm just having a conversation
and kids in school need to wear it above
too dude garcetti man
gar said he just doesn't give a [ __ ] gar
said he's one of those dudes in the
movies where you watch the movie and you
think you're on garcetti's side the
whole movie and then you find out he's
the bad guy
and then you're like oh well at least
this kind of [ __ ] doesn't happen in real
life that's this dude
he's talking about you got to wear your
mask you got to make your mask and then
all of a sudden
just it's a bottom of his face photo
shoot
hey garcetti we don't give a [ __ ] if you
believe in wearing masks or not but just
do what you're telling us to
and don't do a [ __ ] nose and under
photo shoot
the guy's like you got to make sure to
wear your mask wear your mask with your
mask all day long and then all of a
sudden just get
want to see the inside of my lips
just do what you say you're gonna do
otherwise how the [ __ ] can we vote for
you
i'm not saying wear your mask or don't
i'm just saying
if you're a politician and you're saying
wear your mask all the time then wear
your mask all the time that's all i'm
saying
people want to get behind you
so let them
i'm not saying me i'm not saying whoever
but people want to get behind leaders
period
just do what you're gonna do what you're
telling us to
if you're out here saying every morning
wake up do the hokey pokey and then go
to work fine but if some footage shows
up
on some cctv and we see you waking up
and driving to work
and there's no hokey pokey in the middle
of that
then how the [ __ ] are we gonna get
behind you
now i don't like to get political but
you know i mean business
how about this joe rogan thing that's
just absolutely insane
like i know joe rogan personally i know
him for years hey he's just not racist
that's it he's not racist that's it
so okay so yeah he did some [ __ ] which
he said on his apology thing was stupid
and yeah he said those words and he did
those [ __ ] you know the planetary
apes thing and he said well i [ __ ]
did this and that's shitty and everyone
just well not everyone everyone seems to
be on his side which is [ __ ] really
nice when a comedian is going through a
really hard time and a lot of comedians
show up
and uh are there for somebody to support
them which is great but i do support him
because the [ __ ]
he's not racist and yeah he did that
dumb [ __ ] and okay that's it and how
hilarious is it that people are like
saying spotify oh [ __ ] spotify good for
free speech dude spotify doesn't give a
[ __ ] it's about bags dude if [ __ ] joe
rogan left
by the way this is a [ __ ]
hit
this is a hit on joe rogan this has been
out there people know it's been out
there spotify knows it's been out there
i saw that clip a long time ago everyone
knows now it's coming into the light
because they're trying to dig up
everything they possibly can on this
[ __ ] joe rogan
because why because he's bigger than cnn
fox news [ __ ] discovery plus all
together he's bigger than them all
together and that's threatening
so
you know under the guise of doing what's
right they get everybody thinking that
they need to take joe rogan off the air
why dude why because he's a racist guy
no he's not a racist guy and they know
he's not a racist guy also who's saying
he's a racist guy
fox news who who's saying it cnn who's
saying it
it's [ __ ] ridiculous dude
it's so crazy this time and nothing's
happening by the way nothing's happening
he's gonna do his [ __ ] thing anyway
how about that
so you can pretend it's about free
speech you can pretend it's about doing
the right thing you can pretend it's
about being racist anti-racist you can
pretend it's about anything but all it's
really about is money because that's all
it's ever really about and the people
supporting him the friends supporting
him they're only doing it because it's
safe for them because he's the king with
the ring that you kiss that's why
believe believe if it wasn't that way if
it was anybody else but rogan if it was
bert kreicher if it was anybody else
everyone would be wiping their [ __ ]
hands clean of this [ __ ] i
promise you that
and that's not taking anything away from
joe rogan because joe rogan is a good
guy i know him and i know he's not
racist all i'm saying is that this is
about bags the support is about racks
and if it wasn't especially comedians
because they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
they would wipe their hands even knowing
that joe regan
joe rogan isn't racist
they'd be like well i don't contone that
[ __ ]
all these [ __ ] are seeing how
it plays out oh how does it play out
okay then okay then okay then okay good
oh we're good okay then good then i
support it that's what they're doing
dude
that's why i don't post [ __ ] because i
know the [ __ ] and dude here's
the other well i'm saying i support him
now but why why doesn't the [ __ ] uh
uh
i don't know it's weird dude it's just
weird when people go through these times
like
like uh dave chappelle went through his
thing with the [ __ ] with his trans
stuff and everyone was on his [ __ ] like
dude some of the comedy clubs posted
about how we support dave chappelle but
not all of them dude not all of them
they didn't all do it
but they're happily there they'll
happily put him on stage
right
but they won't post about it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it's all about and it's
all about what you think the right thing
to do is to make money you can act like
it's something else oh because i'm
holier than that and i do the right
thing y'all got [ __ ] demons in your
[ __ ] [ __ ] too you got bones in your
closet
everyone did already did the thing that
can bury them
i've said this [ __ ] 200 episodes ago
but the point is
you can't [ __ ]
you can't you just i don't know man
remember the whole thing about [ __ ]
tommy hilfiger and everyone thought that
he was racist because he they thought he
said if i knew black people were gonna
wear my clothing i wouldn't [ __ ] have
made it he didn't even [ __ ] do that
that was like the narrative for so long
people still think tommy hilfiger's
racist and he just didn't do that
people thought he did but he didn't
you'll see a [ __ ] some a black guy
posting the thing at a time he'll figure
thing and under the comments and be like
oh really you're supporting that [ __ ]
racist he's just not that guy i don't
know tommy hilfiger but all i'm saying
is joe rogan isn't racist and the whole
[ __ ] thing is ridiculous it's stupid
as [ __ ]
and it's awesome because rogan just
stays offline and lets it [ __ ] happen
because it's not real if you don't let
it be
um
i just know how much of a [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] it can be when the mob comes after
you and
you know
i checked in with him about [ __ ]
making sure he was okay and he's okay
but it just [ __ ] sucks man it's not
it's not it's not you don't understand
what it's like
and it sucks
um
this is so weird dude
about did you know what's weird is about
um
rick ross here let's go cause we talked
about him last time last time
the piano that played his how
lonely is he
i mean look at this one
[Music]
i'll burn your block down flamethrower
what a what a loser
camera guy just right now so hot just
like oh god
who's doing this oh hit the camera got
backed up into something that's amazing
so [ __ ]
so [ __ ] how he was doing it dude little
spurts of flames
so [ __ ] i love how he dude rick ross
has so much furniture that he thinks he
should have because that's what bosses
have but he doesn't even like it that's
the best part dude how could you be so
lonely this is the thing that happens to
rappers once they get past 40. rap is
such a young man's game that at this
point you're just like okay i guess i
gotta do something to stay relevant like
you can't be a [ __ ] rapper and be 50.
i mean you can kind of but like like
eminem is almost 50 and he's he can
still do it i mean the halftime show was
great dr dre is a producer but like
snoop does it and everyone likes him
because it's funny you know what i mean
nobody's really buying a [ __ ] is
snoop even rapping anymore does it does
he's not coming out with music right if
he was people would be like cool but i
guarantee that's not the [ __ ] thing
that people are yearning for on the
snoop dogg they want him to do a [ __ ]
show with martha stewart or some [ __ ]
right because snoop dogg has just become
a joke of himself and that's fine that's
how he [ __ ] was able to collect racks
at this point in his life but rappers
get so lost right
that they have to like they'll be like
all right i'll just get a flamethrower
and a piano that plays itself and we'll
start [ __ ] doing videos and hopefully
worldstar will repost me and this is how
[ __ ] rick ross will sell tickets now
because he's not going to be like yeah
i'm in my maybach now and [ __ ] is
sucking my dick it's like you're 55 and
that's just
sad grow up that's why ti started doing
[ __ ] stand-up
right t.i sure he's made a lot of money
and he's good for the rest of his life
but he started doing stand-up dude this
is the thing that's [ __ ] hilarious
about stand-up too i know about stand-up
comedians comedians are so [ __ ]
backwards dude comedians will be like oh
[ __ ] stand-up is the hardest [ __ ]
don't take my jobs everyone thinks that
they could do [ __ ] um stand up all
these internet people are popping up and
trying to sell tickets but they're not
why are clubs letting them do it you
know just because this guy went [ __ ]
viral with a guitar the island boys are
gonna do stand up right i'm gonna be
pissed off and then [ __ ] t.i will
come out and be like i'm doing stand-up
comedy right now and he'll go do like 50
minutes at the comedy store and the
comedy store will post them and be like
hey [ __ ] uh troubleman came by and
blessed us with a and it's like dude
what are you [ __ ] doing you cocksuck
you just want you just dude like what
what is ha why are you acting like
stand-up isn't actually a [ __ ] thing
dude it's like yeah if the island boys
want to do it or whoever you're all
pissed off because they're taking the
spots and then troubleman will come in
and just do 50 minutes at the laugh
factory and then people other comedians
will post pictures of it and be like yo
t.i has really been putting in work at
this stand-up [ __ ] it's like dude god
bless this [ __ ] for treating
like a real job dude what are you
talking about this guy
[ __ ] made a song called rubber band
man
he's not a comedian and he's just up
here
just being all like hey what's up man
there's video of i've been doing
stand-up out there and it's [ __ ]
terrible
in no way can it can you be like oh whoa
this is cool he's doing it
you're you're sucking his dick because
he's [ __ ] famous rapper dude how come
i'm the only one who's keeping it real
about this
like it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
i don't even want to get heated i just
want to [ __ ] talk about funny [ __ ]
but this is the [ __ ] that's happening
the guy have a [ __ ] netflix deal in
[ __ ] three months
it's so backwards and makes no [ __ ]
sense
it makes no sense dude
it's so silly bro the whole thing is so
[ __ ] silly
um
nobody gives a [ __ ] because it's about
money
just [ __ ] please believe
that's why everyone's talking about
kanye west like he's a joke like in a
good way like oh that kanye they might
as well just make a sitcom called that
kanye
the guy's having a [ __ ] mental
breakdown hey buddies get him help
get kanye help dude
he that's the thing if you have six
billion dollars you don't have buddies
somebody texted me doesn't he have a
buddy to [ __ ] help
dude you don't have buddies if you have
six billion dollars you have hangers on
dude it's so sad like he's doing this
[ __ ] on instagram talking about he's
gonna somebody's gonna wind up dead dude
he's screaming about how pete davidson
is is a piece of [ __ ] and how he
shouldn't be around his kids dude
kanye's somebody's gonna kill pete
davidson because of this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up get him help get kanye
west help i get it it's exciting when he
goes off the medication and gets an
album mode because you get a good album
but [ __ ] people are going to
wind up dead
is that isn't mental health a real thing
don't you actually care about mental
health awareness then get [ __ ] kanye
west the most famous guy in the world
help dude
oh why because nobody actually gives a
[ __ ] because you only care about money
or the currency of victimization oh that
isn't that what it is you just want to
feel good about yourself by posting
something but not actually believing in
it
right because when it when it's because
it's funny
when it happens to be kanye west because
he's okay because he's got six billion
dollars
oh because you're not treating kanye
west like a person
the hypocrisy is absolutely unreal dude
it's unreal
i mean dude pete davidson or uh kanye
west talk about how
putting somebody in a ch posting an
instagram picture of somebody putting uh
ving rhames putting tyrese in a
chokehold talking about pete davidson
somebody's gonna go out there and
[ __ ] kill pete davidson
it's so [ __ ] up and it's so sad get
kind of hey someone who loves kanye get
[ __ ] kanye west help
like in all seriousness dude
guys [ __ ] losing his mind
it's sad
[ __ ] man i got to do funnier stuff this
sucks dude i didn't mean to get all nuts
how about this stupid commercial that
[ __ ] facebook thought was good a
while ago
god i can't immediately i can't even
imagine these people these these people
that have just way too much money
thinking that this is a good idea
chairs
already hate it
[Music]
chairs are made so that people can sit
down and take a break just the pretense
already you know
chairs
you know what we'll do we'll take
something simple and we'll make it seem
like it matters more
and this way people will be drawn in
because it's something that somebody
uses every day but we'll slap them over
the face at the end but with how
poignant we are that's how we'll do it
we're not even talking about love or war
or famine we're talking about chairs
isn't that quirky
already socks
anyone can sit on a chair
and if the chair is large enough they
can sit down together worst poet
and tell jokes
or make up stories
or just listen um
the music you know for people
and that is why chairs are like facebook
oh for [ __ ] [ __ ] sake dude and that
is why chairs are like facebook okay
let's it's this is not even halfway done
this is embarrassing
oh more things oh god bridges oh jesus
these are things people use condoms
together
key chains
[Music]
oh god basketball dance floors
oregano
[Applause]
[Music]
it is vast
and dark
and makes us wonder if we are alone
no
we're not
there's seven so maybe the reason we
make all of these things
is to remind ourselves
who we are
that we are not alone god damn it
facebook we suck
god
how could they think that's a good idea
and look at the comments dude wow wow
wow i love the vo performance i love how
connected she is to the ideas and the
visuals i mean like what what this is
the kind of person who likes this
[ __ ]
this is the comment wow wow wow wow i
love this vo performance i love how
connected she is to the ideas and the
visual center or her voice subtly
conveys the change in emotion at 1 16
the end when she talks about the
universe like dude this is the kind of
person that just [ __ ] buys the [ __ ]
that just drinks the the kool-aid all
day long this is the kind of person that
likes this commercial the kind of person
who would make this commercial and that
kind of person is not many people
and that's why those people are like
facebook
dude so bad
that was direct by [ __ ] that was
directed by alejandro gonzalez inoritu
wow dude
that's hilarious they get the big and it
and oh god dude trying to be so [ __ ]
this is how we all are and then they get
the guy who directed [ __ ] what was
that
movie with the
no he did uh
the revenant
i don't know i mean he makes some good
movies but jesus christ that commercial
i why are all commercials bad
god it's like they can't do it's 30
seconds make it good it's 30 seconds
dude guys that's our show for today and
if you want to keep listening and get
the rest of the show the uncut version
of congratulations go on over to
patreon.com
every month there's an extra episode and
we also have behind the scenes
um videos that are not released on the
more crystallia channel uh and we have a
review mode section that we do where we
review stuff and uh a lot of behind the
scenes stuff and we have a discord that
we chat on and it's really fun six bucks
a month going over to patreon.com
crystalia thanks a lot guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
all good i'm ready to go